[Music]
yeah
you guys are playing 2K off the Ally or
Wireless wow that's one of the boats
gaming we have the desktop Huang desktop
experience there and handheld mode oh
you know just to show the versatility
yeah
this is pretty cool
acting like a full functional PC right
now
[Music]
[Laughter]
really cool
you're gonna try the melting keyboard
yeah
it was really cool
um
actually have something
guys very impressive advice
and at the Republic of Gamers
checking things out
so it looks like we have like a part of
this breakdown chip set for my tech news
seeing the construction seeing the
process
all the way through
and there it is there it is
get more technical with our Ally right
here breaking it down
Electronics
all the things come together yeah so
yeah the expertise
very very cool
and so now is Network as well which
is like it's time for my favorite laptop
get these beefy boys I'm assuming these
are prototypes early Concepts
yeah they had some ideas for it
some ideas
very cool and here I believe is the
controller that we saw in this una in
action when they were going to desktop
mall
[Music]
it's a typical Xbox got a field
really cool
Minecraft Legends it seems
on this one
I'm sorry
looks like that's in Steam mode
very cool
[Music]
so we're gonna take a little break
Lawrence we got a conference coming up
we're going to get some food and we're
going to change this battery and we will
be back